abone ol
Ya ben Tan Sağtürk ve Bale sanatçısı bir
kere Çok teşekkür ediyorum böyle bir
platformda bana konuşma şansı sandığınız
için şimdi hayatı Mac hayatının gayesi
bir zaman tabi her insan asla kendi
başarı öyküsünü kendisi yaratabiliyor ve
bunun içinde değişik formüller ve
değişik parametreler var yani çocuğumun
var 216 yaşında bir 11 yaşında çocuğum
var E onların hayatlarıyla ilgili acaba
ileride yapacakları konusunda neler
yapacaklar düşündüğüm be onların
hayatlarında belli bir yerlere
girebilmeleri için belirli bir çizgi
ulaşabilmiş olmaları için elbette ki
gibi eğitim vermeye çalışıyoruz önce ama
ne olacaksın ilerde ve ne yetenekleri
var Neye istekleri var henüz ve ufak
çocuğu yaşlı olduklarını düşündüğümüz
için bir keşfetmeye aşamasındayız ve
Dilerseniz ben kendimden yola çıkarak
biraz Anlatmaya çalışacağım biliyorsunuz
bale sanatı çok
bu yaşlarda çalışmaya başlıyor ekonsat
vardı on yıllık zor meşakkatli disiplini
Yok o kadar da zevkli eğitim sürecine
girebilmesi için önce çok yetenekli
arabalarından geçilmesi ve konsantre
girilebilir olmuş olması gerekiyor 41
yıl önce baleye başladım güne için
unutamıyorum Hatta şöyle bir teklif
vardı TRT televizyonu tek bir kanal
vardı o zaman diğer kanallar henüz
kurulmamıştır ve televizyona çocuk
eğlence programına ilkokullar
öğrencilerini taşınmışlar öğrencileri
taşımışlar da onun arasında ben de
vardım konservatuvarda bir hocasına
Şener koreografi yapmak çocukları
düzenlemek için oraya gelmişti hepimiz
gibi bütün Oh eğitmenler öğretmenler
gibi onlar da çocukların yeteneklerini
uzaktan gözlemleyerek belki aralarından
bir tablet yakalarım düşüncesiyle o
gözle bakar nasıl Hoca anneme şunu
söylemiş demiş ki ya tamam Mutlaka
konsolun böyle sınavına girmeleri Çünkü
hareket al
içine kabiliyeti Neyi gördüm Bu
çalışmalar E bunun sebebi ne şundan
kaynaklandığını düşünüyorum ben o
dönemde tekvando ile uğraşıyordum
İstanbul'daki Türkiye teknoloji
Şampiyonası'nda altın madalya almıştım
ya tekvando ile Aslında çok haşır neşir
dedim fakat bale Aklımın ucuna hiç
gelmezdi bile Hayatında bana ne demek
denildiği zaman Çok da fazla bir şey
anlatamıyorum Orada işte annem devreye
girdim yani şöyle bir şansım var diye
düşünüyorum Benim annem bu böylesine bir
teklif alınca sonra amca tarafından on
sayfasına gelsin denilince Annem şöyle
birşey yaptı O an ben çok iyi
hatırlıyorum sanki babamla konuşur gibi
ciddi bir konu var Tamam bunu seninle
konuşmamız gerekir diyerek söyledi Tamam
anne dedim ben de sokakta o zaman
oynayan okula giden ilk okula gider
Sokak Konya bir çocuktum ağaçları
tırmanan Fakat annemin bu konudaki
ciddiyetini görünce karşılık
bir sandalye koydu Evet abi Ben de daha
dikkatli dinle hale geldim anneme eve
şunu sordu Dedi ki sana böyle bir teknik
ve teklif geldi e sınava girmek ister
misin şunu söyledim ya hatırlıyorum
tamam da bari ne demek ona cümlesini çok
iyi hatırlıyorum şöyle benim
çocukluğundan itibaren sana anlattığı
Masallar var bu masalların sahne
üzerinde olduğunu düşünün ona bir de ona
müzik yapamam ki siz olduğunuz için
kırmızı kocaman bir perde açılıyor ve
seyirciyle buluyorsun ve o karakterlerin
dans ederek seyirciyle buluşuyor sunyani
bir masal kahramanı oluyorsun Bunu ister
misin Şimdi ben bu cümleyi hatırlıyorum
bu söyleme çok iyi hatırlıyorum Fakat
onun ne dediğini tekrar sordum Eğer
yıllar geçtikten sonra ne dedim anne ben
sana dedim Evdeki iki gün zaman
istemiştim ben ondan Ee belki geliyor
sonucunda da gelip Anneme ev
Eve girmek istiyorum demiştim sonrasında
Devlet konservatuvar sınavına girdim
Bazı arkadaşlarımızla beraber biz
kazandık 10 saat sonra kontrolü
kazandıktan sonra İzmir devlet masrafını
kazandı ama bu işin Aslında amiral
gemisi Ankara'daki büyük Konsept vardır
hepimiz Aslında orada da kendimizi test
etmek istedik ve e Ankara'ya gidip
okumak istiyorsun 10 yıllık eğitimi
içindeki en son yıllarda Bunlar et Abi
ayran en şey ben şunu söyledim anneme
dedim ki ben gitmek istiyorum Hemen
Gerçekten gitmek istiyorum çünkü Evet
Sizi çok özleyeceğim İzmir'de çok
seviyorum buradaki arkadaşlarımla
bırakıyorum Ama orada gerçekten mesleki
anlamda ne yapabileceğimize enayi
algılayabilmek için benim Gerçekten
gitmem gerekiyor Biz birkaç arkadaşlar
beraber Ankara deniz masa son yolunu
tuttuk çalışmalarımıza orada başladı
konusu oldu ki Ne oldu konservatuvarda
Hani dedik ya hayatın gayesi amacı istek
Ama artık kurulmuş bir robot gibi bir
gören hissettim kendimi yani sanki
hocalar tarafından kuruyoruz sahneye
kuruyoruz ya da eğitime veriyoruz
dinleni yapıyoruz pozisyon dayız o sene
Yani bunu düşünüp de bununla ilgili
çelişkiler kafamda yaşadığım seni
Polonyalı bir hoca gelmişti Polonya'nın
en önemli bir hoca olduğu söylendi Biz
Ee bize bir workshop bir çalışma ortamı
Hazırlandı ve onunla beraber çalışmaya
başladık Ve bize Dersin sonunda şunu
sordu bana istediğiniz soruyu
sorabilirsiniz çocuklar hepiniz birer
not alın blogları tek tek cevaplayacak
ben şöyle bir soru sormuştum sizi
gördüğünüz dünyanın önemli
platformlarında bu işi yaptınız Bizler
öğrenci olarak dünyadaki diğer
öğrencilere göre gördüğünüz yerler diğer
öğrencilere göre hangi sıradayız yerimiz
neresi Onun cevabı şöyle
Evet Ee çok iyi Çalıştık Beraber
gerçekten özel bir gün yaşadık bugün
pembe be Ama bu İlginç bir soru oldu
benim hayatımda pek lela sağlamadan bir
soru çiçeği bu soruyu sorabilir yine
göre Esen dini kendi konumunda önemli
bir yerde bir gün olacağını düşünüyorum
bu soruyu sonra bilen insan önemli bir
yere kendisine konumlandırılacak tır
demiştim sonrasında ise hep daha bir
merak daha bir merak acaba Bundan sonra
ne yapabilirim Ankara'daki eğitimden
sonra ne yapabilirim aslında bütün
arkadaşlarımla beraber direkt oraya
anlaşılabilir bir geçiş yapabilirdik ve
kalmamalı artık ülkemizin birer bale
sarısı olarak meslek hayatına orada
devam ettirebilir dedim fakat yetmeden
Yani ben gerçekten görmek istiyorum
Acaba neredeyim yıkamacım Amerika'da
geldi mi Nerede olduğunu görmek
Avrupa'ya gidip orada bir
bu tartmak vee bütün oradaki alacağım
tecrübe Acaba nasıl kullanabilirim ve
ben sana sevdim rahatsız genç parası
yani böyle Defansa gittim bakın Bunlar
asla bir risk Çünkü daha güvenli bir
liman da kendi tanıdığınız dans
topluluğunda Evet İş gösteriler vermek
yürürken kendinizi bir Bilinmeze Doğru
atıyorsunuz sürekli belki de bundan
garip çıkarmaya da bilirsiniz yeni
edebilirsiniz hasarlı alabilirsiniz
Çünkü küçük bir ceviz kabuğu gibi
düşünün kocaman bir okyanusun ortasına
koyuyorsunuz Ceviz kabuğunu ve bir
kıyıya ulaşmayı bekliyorsunuz Ee burada
bir cesaret var herhalde Ben de ben
tabii Türkiye'de gençlerimizin bu
cesaretine asla hepimizin sahip olduğu
inancındayım Sadece bazen Kendinizi çok
kapattığımız evvel ermez
bu getirebiliyoruz Ebu Bazen çok
istediğimiz bir şey yaptığımız zaman
bazen bir ailem Ailesi aile baskısı
olmuş olabilir ya da bir öğretmenim
yönlendirmesi doğru yönlendirmesi yanlış
yönlendirmesi olabiliyor insanız hepimiz
yani çok iyi bir öğretmen bile bazen
kendi Cümlelerini aktarırken bazen karşı
tarafa doğru anlamda geçmeyebilir
cümleler vee aksi istikamette
oluşturabilir Bütün bunlar olabilir
hayatta da ama olması gereken durun aynı
benim geçirdiği süreç içindeki zaman
dilimi gibi evde oturarak ve benim
yeteneğim de gerek olmuyor mutlaka
kendimizle ilgili bu kadar bilgi akışı
varken Özellikle sosyal medya üzerinden
be bilgisayar üzerinden bu bilgileri
almaya çalışarak sünger gibi aynı
zamanda kendimizi dinlemektedir videoyu
ilgili oluyor e Eğer On yaşında ben
Mesleğimi seçebilecek
çok yaşa geldiğine kanaat getirmiş semti
Bütün Türkiye'deki Ata dünyadaki bale
sanatçıları öğrenir kendi mesleklerini
çok ufak yaşlarda seçmek zorundadırlar
istediği kadar kadar aile baskısının
istediği kadar yetenekli olsun istemeyen
zaten istemiyorum ama bu konuda
gerçekten yeteneğini görmek açısından
değişik alanlara ilgi duymalıyım diye
düşünüyorum bunu bir örnekle pekiştirmek
isterim atlayarak gidiyorum konuyu
tekrar geriye döneceğim Fransa'da
Fransız devlet Balesi ne geçmişti
rahatsız genç polisinden sonra rahatsız
devlet Mahallesi'nde bir diz ameliyatı
geçirmek durumunda kaldım Doktor şunu
söyle Paris'teki e şunu sordum Dedim ki
ben daha edebilecek miyim Tabi yani
yirmili yaşlarda hayatımın tam
kariyerinin en başında böylesine bir
ameliyat bu kadar emek vermişken beni
geri atar mısın şunu söyle bunun için
söz vermiyorum
ve hatta normal ileride yürüyüp
yürüyemeyeceğin konusunda söz vermiyorum
elimizden gelen her şeyi yapacağız Ben
ameliyat olduktan sonra şunu düşündüm
ben acaba bale yapabilir miyim diye
ağlar gözlerle doktora bakarken ya bir
gün yakın bir zamanda bana sen neredeyse
yürüyeceksin defa gelirse cümlesi
kurursa ne yapacağım ne yapacağım bu
kadar Hayatım boyunca on yıl boyunca
emek verdim ailemden uzak durdum yatılı
okul okuduğun ne olacak arkadaşlar
aklıma bir şey geldi Hani İzmirliyim
dedim ya Efesi gezeriz çocukluğumuzdan
beri her sene okullarımız ilkokullar
bizi götürdüğü Efes Antik kentine Ben
arkeolog olmak isterdim Herhalde yani
arkeoloji Peki Paris'te bir arkeoloji
okudu var mı İşte yaptığım yerde yoğun
bakım bir Sonrasında hep onları
araştırdım Acaba bir arkeolojik var mı
Evet Paris'te her ülkede olduğu gibi çok
iyi bir arkadaş okullar peki
bu oraya girebilir miyim acaba Evet
üniversite bitirdim geçerliliği var
Tekrar üniversite sınavına girebilecek
indirebilirim heyecan duydum yani bilim
mesleğin ne kadar amaç gibi gözükür
gözükürse gözüksün Aslında hepimiz için
yaptığımız iş bir araç mış Amaç ne Peki
o zaman yani yaptığımız için ilk mutlu
olmamız için bir araç amaç mutlu olmak
anı yaşamak e kendi yeteneğini keşfetmek
Dünya ile ilişkisini kurmaya çalışmak
yararlı olur halde hissetmek kendimize
Ben bunu yapabilirim demiş olmak bütün
bunları düşünürken bu size yaptığımız
söyleşi gibi birçok üniversitede söyleşi
yapmaya gidiyorum en sıklıkla gittiğim
üniversitelerden bir tanesi ise Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi dir şöyle gözlemliyorum
bazen lise öğrencileriyle üniversiteyle
öğrencilerin arasında
bu farklılıklar oluşacak lise
öğrencileri hayatlarındaki mesleklerin
seçip mutlu olacağım ve istediği
doğrultuda yeteneği doğrultusunda
istediği yere seçip bir üniversiteye
girmeye çalışacağım fakat üniversite
öğrencilerinde bazen üniversite son
sınıfa gelmiş öğrencilerde bile bazen
mezun olduktan sonra orada öğrendiği
mesleği yapmama gibi aldım abi oldu
istatistiklerle bunu göstermiş Oysaki
ben onlardan farklı olarak On yaşında
mesleğim seçmişler bunu benim algılama
imkan yok yani 10 yaşında mesleğini
Seçen biri sanatçılar ise herkes Aslında
ne yapmak istediği doğrultusunda üç
aşağı beş yukarı bir karar bir ve fikre
sahip olabilir diye düşünüyor bunu da
asla çok şanslı olduğumu düşünüyorum
çoğumuzun Evinde internet var bilgi
akışından o meslekler hakkında bilgi
edinmek de mümkün olabilir mesela
O benim oğluma soruyorum Tabii çok ufak
da o Astronot olmak istiyorum diyor peki
astronot olacak elbette ki çok güzel
Acaba astronot olmanın yolu ne olmalı
yani yapacağımız için yolu nasıl olmalı
ve meşakatli tarafı nedir Bunları bu
tarafa gelelim yine Ne hayatın gayesi
amacından Atamızdan hiç kopmadan onun
etrafında dönerek anlatmaya çalışıyorum
Sen beni en çok yere yoran kendi
mesleğinde neler oldu benim mesleğim
beni yormadı benim vücudum O kadar gün
çalışmama rağmen günde 6-7 saat
çalışırdı böyle sana her gün çalışmak
zorundadır Çünkü deriz ki biz bir gün
çalışmazsan kendini hissedersin bir
hafta çalışma seyirci hissetmeye başlar
ve inanılmaz bir rekabet dolu ortam
vardır sanat dünyasında pozitif anlamda
söylüyorum ona rekabetin olmadığı bir
yerde pek başarı çıkmıyorsun ki
O çok yorak Aslında baktığınız zaman
insan ilişkileri aynı kulvara girdiğiniz
zaman çok yakın kendinizi hissettiğiniz
bir arkadaşınızın bile bazen çıkarlar
söz konusu olduğunda insan ilişkilerinde
maalesef bir alttan çekme durumu var
yani Mesleğimi çok iyi yapmam gerekir
dediğimiz yerde aynı zamanda İnsan
ilişkileriyle kendi ortamımız da o
tırnak içinde kıskançlıklar
çekememezlikle egolar bütün bunlarla da
başa çıkmamız gerekecek bunu da başa
çıkmanın tek bir yolu var Baran Ee
hiçbir şey yapmazsanız karşı taraf sizi
Kıskanıyor seni kıskanıyor diye söylendi
bulursunuz ya da kendi konumuzda kısa
hedefler belirleyebilirsiniz ve bu kısa
hedefler bakın uzun hedeflere gitmek
için arada çok engel çıkıyor
çok daha kısa hedefler belirler her
zaman o kısa hedeflere ulaşmak için
bilgi bagajınızı çoğaltmak kalıyor işte
yani onu o konu hakkında daha çok bilgi
edinmek ve neredeyse halk diliyle
konuşuyorum bu işin profesörü olmak
gerekir Öyle olunca size gelen bütün
saldırılar diyelim annelik ya egolar
kıskançlık Aşk bütün saldırılar için
olağanüstü bir kalkan oluşturmuş
oluyoruz o gerekiyor Arkadaşlar bu
dünyanın kuralı pandali zamanında
Gerçekten bu hurmaların kendisi
korumaların daha da fazla şiddetli
artması gerektiğini fark ediyorum çünkü
saldırılar bölünmeler parçalanmalar daha
fazla oluyor Ben Ee Her zaman pozitif
çok neşeli güzel şeyler anlatmak ilk
güzel bu tarafında anlatmayı Seçen bir
insan olmayı tercih ederim günlük
yaşamda bize cizeri bahsetti
O çok neşeli kalkarım sabah 6'da
kalkarım bu cümle O kadar değerli bir
cümleye Elbette ki herkes bulduk her
zaman uygulayabiliyor ben de çok
istiyorum ama şunu yaptım fark ettim Ben
de Gamze el-cezeri gibi Kalktığım zaman
Pencereyi açıp derin derin oluk oluk
nefesine solumaya Özen gösterdim yeni
bir gün başlıyor çünkü dünkü
olumsuzluklar ve onluklar arkada kaldı
bugün yeni bir gün kendi hikayenize
kendiniz bir Resul olarak kontrol
edebilirsiniz sabah nefesimizi aldığınız
zaman ve pozitif anlamda hayata e
hareketinizi hızlandırdığını zaman
Aslında kontrolü size geçmişte
olabiliyor bari genel hayat felsefem
izl1 A4 kağıt olup yazdığımız zaman ben
bunu istiyorum ben şöyle olacağım ben
bunu başaracağım Ben bunu yapacağım
bundan uzak duracağım gibi bir A4 kağıda
yazdım
ve günlük hayatımızda uydurduğunuz da
bütün bunları asla o Gerçekten siz
olmaya başlıyorsunuz kendinizi tanımaya
başlıyorsunuz Mevlana'nın dediği gibi
herkes gel sanki kimse kendi yerinden
mutlu değil gibi hep daha öteye
götürmeye çalışacağım yani İnsanoğlu Ne
garip değil mi Asla Biz bulunduğumuz şu
anda Her neyse her anı doya doya yaşa
bir yaşama heyecanla sahip olmaya
çalışmalıyız bunu yapmıyorsan zaten
yanlış yapıyoruz Hayat boş akıp gidiyor
yani sadece bize verilen yükselmiş olan
görevlerini yerine getirmeye çalışmak
hayatı ki Bence nefes almak şu anda bir
coşku hissetmek bir bence şu anımızı
yaşamalıyız Bu ne onları yaparken
vazgeçmeler de olacaktım istediğiniz bir
şey yaparken vazgeçmeler de olacaktır
mesela dersiniz ki başarmak istiyorum ve
bu yol hareket ediyorum ama okadar
bıktım ki o kadar yoruldum ki
Vazgeçiyorum
bu işte Tam da bu anlarda kendinizi
buldunuz arkadaş grubu bu ya da bir
arkadaş bazen bir baba bazen bir anne
bazen bir kardeş son derece önemli olur
oluyor hale geleceğim Onlar sizin doğru
rehberiniz olabiliyor ama onları
seçimlerindeki mi yapıyor biz yapıyoruz
yani kimin size rehberlik edecek
konusunda seçimlerinizi doğru yapmaz
iseniz Biz o rehber bazen hayatınızda
çok büyük büyük bir şansı yok edebilir
edebiliyor bunu istemeden yapabiliyor Ya
da isteyerek yapıp bilye kendi
rehberimizi kendimiz seçme özgürlüğüne
sahibiz diye düşünüyorum ve konuşmamı
sevgiyle burada son lan